hello i'm doyoung hi i'm hitch and hello
and we all everyone I'm mark I am
tearing ice to meet you hello I'm
jae-hyun I'm Utah nice to meet you I'm
Tay I'm Johnny hey guys would you rather
know all the language in the languages
in the world or know how to play all the
instruments in the world since I mean
more than 100 shots each other so to
either one on and two yogi Kazuma octene
Antonio catches your new body man he's
not a Mori not
Busan manga fashion University comes and
body part you know MOT though Joe pop
you in the some gonna do I've seen and
looked at cut key Anna man she got a mum
to swim in your come to Yemen about
Korean secondary secret elevators of a
bomb Jewish priests chicken knees they
told about the window come on babe okay
Tarzan Hamilton the windows even Tonya
although wedding bouquet want your own
okay
[Laughter]
for the rest of your life or always feel
like would you rather be able to detect
any lie you hear or get away with any
like telling cruising I'm detective
Korea do got the cheesy miss are
Marcinko watching
[Laughter]
would you rather find true love or when
a 500 million dollar lottery sweeter I
can't find love I can't find money oh I
already
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part